Germany's long-distance coach market is
booming these four brand new buses were
bought by jöns de Fattah his company
drives for mine fan bus the country's
market leader in the sector steve father
is confident that his investment will
pay off and that his buses won't end up
standing idle I don't think I'll be
seeing them again any time soon maybe in
three years when they've got nine
hundred and seventy five thousand
kilometers on them that's the contract
we just signed and then I'll return them
but I won't see them again all together
like this because they'll be operating
on different routes Germany's
long-distance coach business depends on
small and medium sized operators to
serve its Europe wide Network Abraha is
a member of the company's partner
Network and he's amazed at how things
have taken off his buses are constantly
on the road when we were first
approached about getting involved we did
initial calculations and said no it's
not on the cards at the moment but when
this route was opened Munich Fire
Paderborn Bela Felton Hamburg we were
approached again by other local
companies already working for bambbles
and wanted to know if he wanted to join
and he's even investing money in the
business now he's having his new coach
decked out in the livery of his main
client day trips alone are no longer
proving profitable hundreds of small and
medium-sized businesses like this are
keeping the long distance coach boom
alive and creating spin-offs for vehicle
branding companies coach manufacturers
are also beginning to profit
hundred long distant coaches are
currently operating in Germany only 100
were bought new but that is changing
after market liberalisation they took a
while for that to actually convert to
orders for us the manufacturers
beginning we couldn't respond to the
dynamism of the market the new business
sprang up so quickly that operators were
forced to draw on their existing fleets
or possibly to buy used vehicles because
they had less than two weeks to get
ready to serve new routes Germany's
biggest used coach market in Stuttgart
developments have also made their mark
150 vehicles used to be parked here but
now there are only 50 long-distance
coaches are now a common sight on
Germany's roads the face of modern coach
travel is changing many passengers are
younger and the routes are frequently
booked out technology training for Coach
drivers their vehicles now come equipped
with what we've come to expect in modern
cars for example driving assistance
systems means that the coach almost
drives itself the drivers are happy with
the new technology
we oughta used to have gearboxes if I
think about shifting eight gears that
was awful compared to today and how of
your customers changed our customers do
have certain requirements that people
didn't used to have such as power
sockets and Wi-Fi and of course that's
all onboard these days we didn't used to
have that my identity regardless the
news was for forgotten II tighten a new
coach now costs around four hundred
thousand euros and while vehicle prices
have risen it's now easier to calculate
profitability thanks to the
liberalization of the long distance
coach market